Isaac Newton considered by many to be
the greatest scientist of all time was
writing towards the end of the
Scientific Revolution when he recorded
an observation that rivaled his three
laws of motion Newton declared
atheism is so senseless and odious to
mankind that it never had many
professors
how's that for a fat Apple falling on
your head atheists
so according to Newton atheism is
senseless it's utterly foolish and
odious it's repulsive it's so senseless
and odious that it never had many
professors
but times have changed because many
people today do profess atheism how did
this happen well if we ask our atheist
friends why atheism has been spreading
rapidly in our time they'll tell us that
atheism is spreading because people are
becoming smarter and wiser and more
enlightened
now our atheist friends insist that they
go where the evidence points they're all
about evidence
but if we have any respect for evidence
and observation and Confirmation and
reality and we look around at the world
can we seriously say that people are
becoming smarter and wiser and more
enlightened or would we say that people
are becoming a bunch of delusional
narcissistic morons who follow evidence
about as much as they follow Newton's
principia
as someone who's been in multiple Mental
Hospitals I can tell you that the world
feels more and more like an insane
asylum every single day
but let's see if we can figure this out
maybe our good friend Bill Maher can
help us Mr Marr you're an atheist you've
been attacking God and Jesus and the
Bible for decades you've seen the world
change over the years
Can you spot any glaring problems in
society
you know the reason why advertisers in
this country love the 18 to 34
demographic because it's the most
gullible
the younger generation is characterized
by extreme gullibility
good to know
a third of people under 35 say they're
in favor of abolishing the police not to
funding
but doing away with a police force
altogether
the younger generation is so out of
touch with reality that they cling to
insane positions
36 percent of Millennials think it might
be a good idea to try communism sounds
dumb to me twenty percent of gen Z agree
with the statement society would be
better off if all property was owned by
the public and managed by the government
and another 29 percent say they don't
know if that's a good idea sounds really
really dumb
So when you say you're old you don't get
it get what abolish the police and the
border patrol and capitalism and cancel
Lincoln no I get it the problem isn't
that I don't get what you're saying or
that I'm old the problem is that your
ideas are stupid their ideas are stupid
but the younger generation is too dumb
and gullible to realize it and Bill
points out that this isn't just true of
the younger generation the entire nation
has become so utterly moronic that we
may not be able to solve the problems
that we Face finally new rule before we
tackle any of our daunting specific
problems here in America we have to
figure out how a country can solve any
problem if so many of its people are so
intractably astoundingly mind-numbingly
stupid we might need to just shut it
down
I mean this country just might be
empirically verifiably too dumb
to continue as an ongoing Enterprise
and what about the education system
this country simply has no education
standards anymore they will let you out
of a public high school and give you a
diploma and you don't have to actually
know anything so we've become ignorant
stupid and gullible
anything else going on yes atheism has
been growing so rapidly that Bill Maher
wants an atheist holiday but while
approximately three million Americans
celebrate Ramadan 100 million say they
have no religion at all what the
where's our day a hundred million people
in the U.S have no religion at all
atheists we're approaching a third of
the population now I shouldn't have to
beg for this for God's sake come on Bill
atheists already have a holiday
April 1st
the fastest growing religious group in
the United States are nuns no not the
kind who used to beat you with a ruler
for being left-handed
I mean people who when asked how much
they want to be involved with a religion
say none that's interesting the fastest
growing religious group is words not
mine the fastest growing religious group
are the people with no religion at all
are nuns they're called nuns what's your
religious affiliation
none
how much Common Sense do you have none
the unaffiliated share of the population
consisting of people who describe their
religious identity as atheist agnostic
or nothing in particular has risen from
five percent in 1972 to 15 percent in
2005 to 32 percent today you're welcome
so we can thank people like Bill Maher
for increasing the percentage of nuns
from five percent in 1972 to 32 percent
in 2023 and the numbers get even better
for the younger generation
Millennials are the first generation
that are less than a majority Christian
their idea of hell is a coffee shop with
no Wi-Fi it's the first generation in
U.S history that's minority Christian
when asked how often they go to church
34 percent of younger Millennials
answered seldom slash never or don't
know
atheists of the world rejoice
fewer and fewer young people are going
to church and many of them are so
insanely stupid that they don't even
know if they go to church
that must be good news for our atheist
friends obviously with so many young
people abandoning religion and becoming
atheists that Utopia of rationality and
science must be right around the corner
that was the promise of the new atheists
wasn't it
if we can just escape the evil Talons of
Christianity we'll get a new dawn of
intellectual progress and scientific
reasoning
is that what's been happening
does Bill Maher even hear what he's
saying
watch how easy this is to put together
on the one hand bill is boasting about
the rise of atheism the rise of the nuns
the decline of Christianity look at all
the people who are becoming atheists
on the other hand he's complaining about
how stupid and gullible people have
become look at these gullible morons
they're so dumb they'll fall for
anything they're so dumb they want to
abolish police altogether they're so
dumb they think communism is a good idea
they're so dumb they graduate from high
school without knowing anything about
the world they live in they're so dumb
they're
becoming atheists at an unprecedented
rate
I find this fascinating atheists are
bragging they're thumping their chests
they're celebrating because a generation
that is characterized by extreme
gullibility and extreme ignorance and
extreme stupidity a generation that can
be manipulated into believing absolutely
anything no matter how insane this
generation just happens to be the
generation that's turning away from
Christianity and towards atheism
and the Dumber they become the more
progress they think they're making
for most of human history the options
were monotheism or polytheism atheism
was as Isaac Newton put it senseless and
odious to mankind
how do you get people to accept
something that's senseless and odious
you need a generation that's programmed
to accept senseless and odious ideas
welcome to the Idiocracy
I can't say it's what we need
but it's definitely what we deserve
[Music]
foreign